the countdown is on to election day only
about a week from tomorrow
hundreds of thousands have already cast
their ballot in our state joe moeller is
live in centennial hills
with more on voter turnout so far joe
hey there this is the last week to
actually vote early we're at centennial
center in centennial hills and this is
actually the busiest polling location
here in the valley take a look
here live dozens of people waiting to
get inside and cast their ballots so far
more than 16 000 people have voted
just at this location now take a look at
early voter turnout so far this year
during the first week there
were around 194 thousand votes in clark
county
in 2016 during the first week there were
233 thousand votes so we were actually
down in comparison to the
last election for early votes in nevada
nearly 700 000 people have already voted
either in person or by mail
we caught up with some voters here in
centennial hills who say the
ballot was a little overwhelming with
the number of judges on there they
suggest doing your homework before going
to the polls
yeah we did we looked at all of the
different recommendations
and then we marked all of our ballot and
then came here and it was only
a few minutes so i did my homework so it
was easy
use my ballot sample ballot and i was
able to click from there it was easy i
made work
if you wanted to early vote you can do
so through friday polls are all over the
valley and there is a map online to show
wait times
in 2016 there were twenty thousand more
voters during the second week of early
voting so we could expect polls to get
a little bit busier now back out here
live this location here in centennial
hills does close at seven like many
others do
we do have a link to the times and the
locations up on our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live in
centennial hills joe mohler 8 news now